Google self-driving car may look and
kind of sound like an overgrown Roomba
but inside it's packing some of the most
advanced software the auto industry has
ever seen the car uses sensors like
cameras radars and laser detection to
interpret the world around it that
software lets it not just recognize
things like police cars pedestrians and
errant cyclists but actually predict how
they're likely to act inside the
controls for things like windows lights
and heating look like they were torn out
of a 90s era Ford Taurus but the real
cool part is that you don't get a
steering wheel and you don't need pedals
that's because Google's not interested
in anything less than a fully self
driving car and it wants to get there in
four years this prototype will almost
certainly never be sold to the public
but it's a clear sign of how serious
Google is about reducing driving a
little more than getting in pushing the
Go button and enjoying the ride